life coaching from jay-z before he was a
billionaire entertainer known as jay-z
shawn carter was a drug dealer who
worked the public housing projects of
brooklyn looking back in his early years
even he seems incredulous about his
almost unbelievable rise the streets of
Brooklyn in 1986 were a lot different
than the gentrifying neighborhoods there
today hip-hop was on the rise but the
environment was rough with addicts
lining the streets and crime Wars being
waged throughout neighboring buildings
at age 15 Shawn Carter had two primary
activities one was writing rap lyrics in
his kitchen the other was selling crack
in the stairwells of the Marcy housing
projects when he looked in his future
with role models and success stories few
and far between the only real options he
saw were too clearly opposing career
tracks option one professional drug
dealer option two professional
entertainer both of these careers were
long shots with success not guaranteeing
it either way notwithstanding the legal
and moral issues of selling cocaine
perhaps the better short-term choice
would have been to continue with drugs
there was an immediate payoff in cash
and tax-free status was also higher in
Brooklyn in the 1980's drug dealers were
some of the most powerful and feared if
not always respected people in the
community lastly being a drug dealer was
relatively easy the young Shawn Carter
knew how to sell drugs it was a market
with virtually limitless domain and he
had a client base that kept coming back
again and again the status quo decision
and perhaps the most likely one was to
continue selling drugs but as we know he
didn't Shawn Carter didn't become a
famous drug dealer and that's a good
thing since most famous drug dealers are
dead in the music industry there's no
guarantee of stardom the consequences of
failure are usually much lower if you
fail you have to get a day job if you
fail in drug dealing however you go to
prison or die but even with morality
rishta side chances are that none of us
would know jay-z's name if he hadn't
chosen the life of rhyme above the life
of
I he wouldn't be worth a billion dollars
he probably wouldn't have won Beyonce's
heart and the odds are high that he'd be
incarcerated if not dead here's how
jay-z described to success years later
the reach that this music had for me was
unbelievable of course luck plays a part
in it but every human being has genius
level talent there are no chosen ones
you have to find what you're great at
and tap into it pursuing a career in
music wasn't just about making a better
ethical and lifestyle choice it was also
about making the right career choice the
choice to do something he loved
something he could get paid well for and
something he was skilled at you might
not be facing the same dilemma between
drug dealing and superstardom but you
can use a similar method of analysis to
make your own career choices